cuál de las siguientes gráficas
representan las soluciones del sistema
de ecuaciones y aquí tengo x es igual a
1 x martín es igual a 1 y por otra parte
x es igual a ye cuadrada menos 10 ok y
tengo 4 respuestas posibles esta gráfica
de azul esta gráfica de rojo rosa o
verde y bueno aquí me piden que ponga
cuál es mi respuesta para esto quiero
que te des cuenta de lo siguiente yo lo
que quiero saber es qué es lo que pasa
con esta ecuación cuadrática que tengo
aquí si supiera bien qué es lo que pasa
aquí ya podría saber casi todo porque si
te das cuenta tengo parábolas distintas
bueno estas dos parábolas se parecen
mucho pero vamos a ver si esta es una
parábola que abre hacia arriba y bueno
en definitiva no es una parábola que
abre hacia arriba porque las palabras
que apenas hacia arriba son de la forma
y bien es igual a algo por equis
cuadrada ok
más todos los demás términos y este algo
está debería de ser mayor que 0 ahora en
este caso no pasa eso si te das cuenta
tenemos que x x déjame ponerlo con otro
color tengo que x es igual a algo porque
cuadrada más todos los demás términos y
si te das cuenta aquí el coeficiente que
está al lado de la ye cuadrada a vale 1
que por cierto es un número mayor que 0
por lo tanto estamos hablando de una
parábola que abre oa la izquierda oa la
derecha ahora para saber si habla a la
izquierda oa la derecha es simple y
sencillo fijarnos qué es lo que pasa con
am como a es un valor positivo estamos
hablando de una parábola que abre hacia
la derecha y bueno la única palabra que
abc la derecha es esta de verdad que
tengo aquí esta de verde es la única que
habla es la derecha así que tomemos el
color verde si te das cuenta también
tiene toda la lógica del mundo porque
esta parábola este de aquí pasa por el
origen y si nosotros nos fijamos en el
punto cero
esta función se cumple 0 es igual a 0 al
cuadrado menos 0 de lujo por lo tanto
estamos hablando de esta parábola de
verde y de una manera muy rápida
podríamos decir que ya acabamos el
problema porque la única parábola que se
parece a esta ecuación es esta parábola
de verde y podemos concluir que es esa o
no espera porque además dice que ninguna
de las anteriores o que revisemos
también qué es lo que pasa con la recta
la recta es de la forma x más igual a 1
aquí la voy a poner x + ye igual a 1
ahora sí vemos esta recta en su forma
pendiente orden al origen
me quedaría que james es igual a menos x
más 1 si despejó alguien y de aquí estoy
diciendo que interceptó al eje de las 10
en el valor de 1 que es justo este valor
de aquí vamos bien con esta recta de
verde y que tenemos una pendiente
negativa de -1 es decir por cada uno que
camina la derecha voy a bajar uno por
cada uno que camine a la derecha voy a
bajar uno y de lujo llegó a este punto
aquí por lo tanto si estoy hablando esta
recta de verde ahora si estoy segurísimo
estoy hablando de esta recta de verde de
esta parábola de verde y por lo tanto
puedo asegurar que las soluciones de
este sistema de ecuaciones son
precisamente la gráfica de verde podría
yo rellenar este circuito y revisar que
mi respuesta estuviera bien ahora si yo
quiero encontrar las soluciones de este
sistema déjenme aquí poner este circuito
si yo quiero encontrar soluciones de
este sistema pues fíjate que son los
puntos en donde se intersectan ambas
ecuaciones es decir en donde se
intersectan ambas gráficas que es este
punto de aquí y este punto de aquí y
este punto de aquí tiene como
coordenadas el 0,1 cuando x vale 0 vale
1 y este punto de aquí tiene como
coordenadas 2 coma menos uno menos uno
ok 0.12 como al menos uno y si tú
verificas en estas dos ecuaciones que
tengo aquí sustituyendo cada uno de
estos puntos te vas a dar cuenta que en
efecto son las soluciones de este
sistema de ecuaciones son donde se
intersectan estas dos gráficas